can you describe at a high level
what are
the different schools of economics
perhaps ones that are interesting to you
perhaps
ones that
the difference between which reveals
something
[Music]
useful or insightful for our
conversation okay so you know you could
neoclassical post-keynesian austrian
i like the biophysical
uh economics and so on other heterodox
economic schools that you find
interesting okay i actually find
interesting school which went extinct
about 250 years ago
that's where i'd like to start from and
they're called the physiocrats
and the name itself implies where their
knowledge came from because
if you go back far enough in history we
didn't we didn't do autopsies but when
you started doing autopsies they found
wires they found tubes etc etc and they
started seeing the body as a circulation
system and they applied the same sort of
logic to the economy
and they came out of an agricultural
economy which was france and they saw
that the wealth came effectively from
the sun
so they saw all wealth comes from they
said the soil but what they really mean
is sun the soil absorbs the energy of
the sun one seed plants a thousand fluid
seeds come back there is no surplus uh
we are simply mining what we can find
out of the natural economy that's where
we should have stayed and developed from
that forward uh we then went through the
classical school of economics which
comes out of adam smith and smith uh
coming from scotland
looked at what the physiocrats said and
what the physiocrats argued was that
agriculture is the source of all wealth
and the manufacturing sector is sterile
that's literally the term they use to
describe the manufacturing what is that
their own means sterile means you don't
you don't extract value you simply
change the shape of value so the the
value
comes from the soil the only comes from
the soil that's the free gift of nature
that's literally the phrase they used
and we then distribute the free gifts of
nature around and we need carriages
which was the manufacturing term they
used at the time
as well as
wheat
so we to make the carriages we take
what's been
taken from the soil and we convert it to
a different form but there is no value
added in manufacturing yeah so smith
looked at that and said well i'm from
scotland
and we've got these you know
industries you know we make stuff and
it's machinery and he said no it's not
land that gives it the source of value
it's labor
yeah now that led to the classical
school of thought and that said that all
value comes from labor
uh that
value is objective so it's the amount of
effort you put in that the price two
things will exchange for reflects the
relative effort that's involved in the
manufacturing so this computer takes two
hours to make and this bottle takes two
minutes to make then there's this is
worth 60 times as much as that okay they
didn't talk about
marginal cost it was absolute cost
effectively they didn't talk about
utility as a subjective thing they
ridiculed subjective utility theory
that led to marx and marx is
probably the most brilliant mind in the
history of economics the only other
competitor i'd see is schumpeter
possibly keynes but in my terms of
ranking of intellects of you marx
schumpeter keynes in terms of the
outstanding
capacities to think but marx then turned
that classical school which was
pro-capitalism and anti-feudal into a
critique of capitalism
which led to the neoclassical school
coming along as a defense of capitalism
but they defended it using the ideas of
the subjective theory of value so that
value does not reflect effort it's the
satisfaction
individuals get from different objects
that determines their value marginal
utility it's the marginal cost that
determines how much they sell for
capitalism equilibrates marginal cost
and marginal utility
and
the concepts of equilibrium and marginal
this and marginal that became the
neoclassical school and that's still the
dominant school now 150 years later
so that's the one that everybody learns
and when you first learn economics if
you don't have the critical background
that i managed to acquire
that's what you think is economics the
marginal utility equilibrium
oriented analysis of mainstream
economics and for example they ignore
money
and people thinks economists you must be
an expert on money because you're an
economist well in fact economists learn
literally in the first few weeks at
university that money is irrelevant
they say money illusion so they they
represent people's uh tastes using what
they call indifference curves and
they're like isoquants on a on a weather
map if you look at an isoquant it shows
you all the points of the same pressure
so you can be you can be here or you can
be in denver and the air pressure can be
the same if you're in the same weather
unit so you just draw a cell little
links together well they do the same
thing with utility and say lots of
bananas and very few coconuts can give
you the same utility as lots of coconuts
and very few bananas and you draw a
basically a like a hyperbola running
down and linking the two and they'll say
well that's that's your utility that
describes your tastes and then we have
your income and there's given your
income you can buy that many um bananas
completely or that many coconuts or a
straight line combination of the two
and then if we double the price
nominal price of coconuts and double the
normal price of bananas and double your
income what happens and the correct
answers are nothing sir you know you
stay at the same point of tangency
between what your budget is and which
particular
utility curve gives you the maximum
satisfaction
so that gets ingrained into them and
they think anybody who worries about
money suffers from money illusion
you know you you are therefore
ignorant of the deep insights of
economics if you think money actually
matters
so you have an entire theory of
economics which presumes we exchange
through data
you know like i'll i'll swap you that
microsoft surface for
actually i'll take two of those for one
of these you know we do this bartering
type arrangement in fact that only works
if money plays no creative role in the
economy
and that's where you'll find reading
schumpeter
the inside that's the school of thought
that i come from that says money is
essential
money actually adds to demand and i'll
talk we'll talk about that later on so
that's the neoclassical school that ends
up being subjective theory of value
uh
non-monetary
so everything happens in bata
and focusing on equilibrium as though
everything happens in equilibrium or if
you get disturbed from equilibrium you
return back to it again
and
that mindset describes capitalism his
most interesting feature is that it
reaches equilibrium
now what planet are we on to believe
that because if you look at the real
world the real
uh
exciting world of capitalism in which we
we live change
is by far the most obvious
characteristic of it there's no
equilibrium there's no equilibrium it's
unstable and like as a mathematician
it's easy to you know you work with
stability analysis you know you work out
what the uh the jacobian is you work out
your little open of exponents in a
complex system you're used to the idea
that equilibrium is unstable but
economists get schooled into believing
that everything
happens in equilibrium and they don't
learn stability analysis so all that
stuff is missing so onto the schools of
thought
the
treating the economy as an equilibrium
system
which was what the class neoclassical
school did is what keynes disturbed
and he really disturbed it by talking
about
but fundamentally that uncertainty
determines
our decisions about the future
so when we consume you know you know if
you like fires or whatever the
particular drink you want to have you
know the current situation but to invest
you must be making guesses about the
future
but you don't know the future so what do
you do you extrapolate what you
currently know and this he said this is
a terrible basis on which to
plan for the future but this is the only
thing you can do when there where there
is no possibility of solid calculation
so investment is therefore subject to
uncertainty
and therefore you will get volatility
out of out of investment you will get uh
fads of course booms and slumps coming
out of that because people extrapolate
forward the current conditions and
that's the normal state of a capitalist
economy and schumpeter argued that
that's what gives us this creativity as
well
the fact that you
can perceive a potential demand but you
don't first of all you don't know
whether that demand is going to work
secondly you don't know who your
competitor is going to be whether
somebody's going to be ahead of you or
behind if there's a fad you'll over
invest okay
all this stuff is the real nature of
capitalism and that's what we should be
trying to capture the dynamic
non-equilibrium monetary
violence and creativity of capitalism
that's what we should be analyzing and
the post keynesian school
has gone in that orientation
they've been in my opinion inhibited by
learning their mathematics from
neoclassical economists so they don't
have enough of the technology of complex
systems it's only a really tiny handful
of people working in complex systems
analysis in post-keynesian economics but
that is to me the most interesting area
so their their tools may be lacking but
they fundamentally accept the
instability of that's right that's right
and so that's what makes them
interesting so let me let me try to
summarize what you said and then you say
how stupid i am okay so then there was
the uh
physiocrats
that thought value
came from the land yep then there's adam
smith
who said
nah
value comes from human labor
uh
that was that was the classical school
and then neoclassical
is uh value comes from
like bananas and coconuts the pre human
preference is
like human happiness how happy
how happy a banana makes you
and then uh the kenzian and the
post-kansan were like
yeah well you can't
you can't you can never the moment you
try to put value to a banana and a
coconut you're already working in the
past
yeah yeah
it's always going to be chaos and
stability and then you just
you're you're fishing in on certain
waters and that's we have to embrace
that and come up with tools that model
that well
you